wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
ist er sicher
wir leben hier seit mehr als einem jahr
wir kriegen unsere heimat wird noch
lange dauern
meine frau liebt dieses land und meine
tochter hatten die chance hier zu
studieren
ich plane eine zukunftsfähige und ich
habe so eine gute zukunft zu haben
ich bin kein fachmann eben aber du
kommst nicht aus einem eu land und ich
glaube nicht haben wir keine abschlüsse
werden einfach so anerkannt das weiß ich
und trotzdem lässt sich eine eigene
praxis eröffnen nicht sofort vielleicht
mal ein paar jahren
ich habe ja gesagt meine familie
verdient eine zukunft in diesem land
ich finde das kind so was ist mir dann
aber im krankenhaus
auch dafür muss ich meinen abschluss
anerkennen lassen und sprach prüfungen
ablegen und als mediziner neu zugelassen
werden verstehe es gibt bei bedarf in
deutschland es gibt viel zu wenige
hausärzte und ich hätte zeit für meine
familie als arzt im krankenhaus
hast du überstunden nachtschichten das
ist anstrengend bitte ich muss mich sehr
viele dinge kümmern und rufen was meinen
abschluss anerkannt wird
dann muss sich auch prüfungen ablegen
und vielleicht weitere prüfungen
absolvieren
das kostet viel zeit und geld und in
dieser zeit da kann ich nicht von
arbeiten und das gilt für meine familie
zu verdienen
man muss die miete gezahlt werden was du
brauchst ist ein kredit
[Musik]